頂尖的AI研究者跟諾蘭說,
現在是他們的奧本海默時刻,
諾蘭很高興他們回頭看歷史,
只是這個故事他研究了這麼久,
不確定裡面有具體的答案可以學。
這段對談是科學節Starmus今年9月初公開的,場合是頒給他霍金科學傳播獎章,他是2024年的得主。
跟他對談的Keep Thorne,拿過諾貝爾物理學獎,也是星際效應的科學顧問。
第一個問題由他來問,問的是何物?
我回想起1950年和1960年
我和我藝術家和政治家都很擔心
政治家和公眾都很擔心
核彈危險
我當時在蘇聯時期
也有很多時間
擔心和擔心
在俄羅斯的風險,最高,如果不是更高,就像在這裡
這讓我們覺得這是一個穩定的因素,保護我們
在電影中,你形容這兩隻冰箱的兩隻蝴蝶
美國和蘇聯
世界有所改變,
現代人大多數不知危險。
您的電影《奧芬海默》提升了一些知識,
我非常高興看到您的電影。
您的目標是什麼?
與奧普汗海默認識
這是您的目標
提升這件事的知識
您對此有什麼看法
經過花了大量時間
討論與奧普汗海默
並創建這部電影
廣泛地說
我的業務
總是關於故事
只是關於劇情
廣泛地說
但與奧普汗海默有關
當我第一次告訴
我跟一位我年輕的兒子說
我當時大約16歲
他跟我說過
他告訴我
核武
這不是我們在擔心的事了
我非常非常驚訝
我認為
這就是為了
製作這部電影的原因
兒子那句話
還給了他一個提醒
觀眾走進戲院的時候
心裡不一定還惦記著何物
電影得自己把那份威脅演出來
我非常擔心你所說的問題
無論你認為核武必須被全面滅絕
或你認為這是一個實際的想法
或是,正如有些人所說的
在歷史上,相關的和平
相關於世界大戰1和世界大戰2
你認為核武必須被維持
事實上,核武必須被維持的概念
只能用正確的恐懼和尊敬
核武的極端力量
所以無論你對核威脅的看法
我個人認為
核武的少數在地球上
最好是完全停止
這就是簡單的看法
但無論你對核武的看法
無論你掌握
《共產主義的短暫毀滅》的哲理
只能用
如果我們一直在擔心
壓迫世界領袖
以降低核武量的數量
並且保持正確的尊重
他們所展示的獨特的威脅
當電影播出時
我認讀了一或兩個
從這個領域的工作人員
更加悲觀的批評
他們不錯地指出
電影結束時
感到疲憊
我認為這很重要
他也承認這樣收尾有代價
觀眾可能因此看不到1945年以來削減核彈頭的成果
他說人對核武的恐懼一直跟著國際情勢起伏
電影開拍那時候俄烏局勢惡化
大家才又談起來
他認為不該這樣
接著發問的是Starmus的共同創辦人Garrett Israelian
它可以改變很多其他東西,但它可以破壞我們。
所以,人們說,一切都在我們手裡,
但是什麼會改變我們呢?我們必須被改變。
我認為,在科學歷史中,
社會和人類自然的自然能夠
配合科學發掘,
而我認為,這從來沒有
發生過這麼嚴重的發生,
例如冰箱爆炸。
但我認為這個問題一直存在
知識和責任之間
知識可以有危險性
即使是有幫助
但它仍然承擔力量
承擔新技術的責任
我過去六個月
特別談論了
阿富汗的故事
以及我們現在正在與自然智能認識的情況下
我一直被鼓勵
與AI專業的主要研究家談論
他們說的這就是他們的 Oppenheimer 時刻
因為對我來說
這意味著他們正在看待過去
他們正在看待歷史的例子
尤其是 Oppenheimer 的故事
作為一個閃耀的故事
他們說
我們可以從這件事學習什麼
他們認識了 Oppenheimer 的故事
我並不確定
確實是有特定的答案要學習
這就是我所說的有趣、有複雜的故事
它是非常複雜的
並充滿了不容易回答的問題
但我對於這方面很高興
他們會考慮到這方面
並說好,我們應該真正注意到
新的技術
無論有多激烈或有多激烈
都會有很嚴重的意圖
我認為這很在AI的討論前面
我認為這是一件好事
Keep Thorne接著提到電影裡的一場戲
原子彈投下之後
奧本海默進白宮見杜魯門總統
說他覺得自己手上沾了血
然後在他在其他地方使用的語言中批評
在這裡,我必須擔心這些東西,這是你做的事,這是我的責任
但是當你到達這種程度時,那些科學家到什麼程度需要承擔責任?
創作者需要負責任,那他們可以負責任嗎?
這對政治和科學有很複雜的互動。
我認為奧賓海默的故事,
我經過這部電影的結尾後,
我更深入地思考,
與觀眾討論,
我更深入地意識到,
當奧賓海默離開了辦公室的那一刻,
這對我來講,
我把我的手指放在這裡
它代表了科學與政治之間的關係
科學與建築物之間的關係
這是科學與傳媒之間的大問題
這是AI與科學與傳媒之間的大問題
因為它所導致的
在全面討論關於 climate change 的討論中
和科學與傳媒之間的討論中
科學與科學與傳媒之間的討論中
因為如果科學與建築物之間的關係
科學與政治建築物之間的關係
科學被媒體迫去執行這種關係
這意味著科學被騷擾
這是一個問題
科學家被迫被騷擾
試圖發生關係的擔憂
他們失去信任
因為它變得容易被破壞
因此,
您所見的環境改變,
有些更嚴重、更嚴重的意見容易被揭穿,
因為它們不是,
你知道,
科學在那種意義上並不可揭穿,
但表達現實是更複雜的,
這需要政治上做的,需要專門的專家,需要科學者的團體,
需要政府的指導,要知道真正的科學,需要做的什麼。
這不能全都通過媒體來做,但是我認為,
奧巴汗的故事是一個重要的時刻,
那開始成為了一個事實,突然間,
有一個三腳踏實,你知道,
曼哈頓計劃在秘密上發生了。
所以政府與科學之間的關係,
叫它惡劣的,
突然變成了媒體的第三個目標。
這對政治家與科學家之間的關係不一,
我認為我們一直都在受到這種影響。
這是一個非常複雜的問題。
我認為真正的解決方案,
或者目標,
最好的可能的關係
是最瞭解的人
和政策的人
而不是在公眾領域
不斷地演繹
而是要有
成功的專業討論
但是這必須
受到公眾壓迫
沒錯
所以我們必須
向公眾傳達科學
公眾必須
對政治家發出壓迫
是的,而且很複雜的事情是如何保持科學的精神
後來Garic問他,太空競賽激勵過一整代人,下一個會是什麼?
諾蘭先講了重返太空跟火星
所以我對太空和火星有很大的看法
我對太空和火星有很大的看法
包括探索、距離和發掘
但這對每個人都很親切
例如在AI的領域
有很多危險和缺乏使用
但實際上的實際使用
以及年輕人能夠使用這種技術
在畫面上
在新的故事、新的技巧
新的表現方式上
這將會是未來的年輕人的想象力
AI研究者想從奧本海默的故事裡找答案
諾蘭不確定裡面有現成的
她看到的是科學跟政治
從那時候起就斷了線
不過她沒有因此看壞AI
她認為年輕人會拿她說出新的故事
原影片《21分鐘》
她最後還講到科學現在被當成政治足球在踢
她認為解法是教育
因為在人類想出來的所有哲學裡
只有科學會設法推翻自己
開頭Kip Thorne還講了霍金看完星際效應有多興奮
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多